Well, good afternoon.
Thank you all for being here.
Um,
Thursday of reinvent, we're coming up on
the end. Hope everybody has had
a great week as you put your headsets on.
Um, hopefully everybody has had a great week,
uh, and done all of the great reinvent things
networking.
Learning, uh, having the Vegas
experience and, and doing it all,
um, and I, I will put in a plug hopefully
you've saved a little bit of energy
for the replay party tonight. For me it's
always a fun way to kind of wrap the business
part of the week and, and have some fun,
uh, celebrating, uh, what's happened. So
I always love to find out
people's experience at reinvent. How many are
here for their first ever reinvent?
Wow, lots of first timers. That's fantastic.
Love it. Welcome. Hopefully it's been a good
week and you're already booking your flight for next year.
Uh, how many on the other end, 5
or more?
Alright, awesome. So these are veterans
you new newcomers can see
that they've had a good time and they keep coming back. So,
well again thank you so much for being here. Um,
by way of introduction, my name is Tim Honeychurch.
I am a, uh, uh, uh, principal
specialist in cloud governance, uh, here
at AWS.
I'll be joined, uh, later in the presentation
by our valued customer,
uh, Dustin Jeffers of Eli Lilly and
Company. And then my colleague
here at AWS,
uh, Alex Morita, but I have the privilege
of getting us started and, uh, we'll do
that by taking a quick look, uh, at
our agenda.
Um, I'm gonna spend the first part of the presentation
laying down the foundation of
what cloud governance is,
uh, and how it relates to the topics
that Dustin and, and, uh, Alex
will be talking about.
Dustin's gonna come up and tell a real
life story. This is one of our, our favorite
things to do is tell a real life story
about problems to be solved,
solutions that were available, uh,
how that process went, and then what the
outcome was. So we're looking forward to hearing from
Dustin about, uh, what it meant for Lily.
And then Alex will come in and do
some more detailed uh
deep dive on some of the technical elements
of that solution that that Lily
employed. So, uh, 3 parts
and hopefully it all connects for you and you
come away with some things that are useful
that you can take back to your operations.
So does that sound good?
Alright, ready? Let's, let's get into it.
So you know one of the the things that
we love to talk about at AWS
is the speed of innovation
that is enabled by the cloud, right? So customers
come to us,
um, because they wanna move faster they have business
projects, objectives, outcomes that they're
looking for, and they wanna take advantage
of some key characteristics of the cloud,
uh, to help them get there.
You know, one is to move faster, and
what we'll be talking about today is how
we enable these capabilities
through our cloud governance services
that are part of Lily's story.
So from a moving faster perspective,
our customers want to
utilize capabilities like
auto scaling and dynamic
resource provisioning to be
able to add resources quickly as
part of their development process and not
be slowed down by
legacy IT type of
operations. Agility is
key. Our customers want to be agile.
They want to be able to
move quickly in their development cycles,
spin up resources to be able to
do what they need to do in their projects
without being bogged down by
operational requirements and centralized
IT. And they
also want to be able to scale, right? You wanna
get big and you wanna get fast and you wanna be efficient.
You wanna be able to deploy, uh,
policies such as uh S3 bucket
encryption across all of your S3 buckets,
maybe thousands of them across hundreds of
accounts,
and you wanna be able to do that in one motion
using uh scaled capabilities,
and those are the things we'll be talking about
today in our presentation.
Before we get too far into it though, I do wanna lay
a bit of a foundation, uh,
uh, uh, a foundational definition
of cloud governance. So in my role
and in what we do here at AWS,
we look at cloud governance as a way
to enable you to take advantage
of the things that the cloud offers. You came here
to do something specific,
and we like to use the capabilities and governance
to help you get there, to align your use
of the cloud, uh, with
those business objectives.
And while we talk about cloud governance kind
of as a topic, we know it's made
up of some interconnected components
so there's a security element, there's an
operations element, there's a compliance element and
a cost element,
and we like to orchestrate these things with cloud
governance capabilities to help
you move faster
while also adhering to the requirements,
uh, and, and the standards that you
have across those domains.
So as we get into the more technical
content. Just be thinking about that definition,
right, a set of tools capabilities
that helps you align your use
of the cloud
with what you're trying to achieve.
But you know we know that implementing
these things is not necessarily easy
or automatic and you'll hear from Dustin
that there's work involved, uh, in, in accomplishing,
uh, what they were able to accomplish,
um, you know, and, and one of my
favorite things about the role that I have
now at AWS
is that I talk to customers a lot,
right, and I hear from customers about what they're
trying to achieve.
Um, what the challenges
are in, in their world, the
unique requirements and, and, and what they're
trying to, uh, customize
to help them solve problems for their business.
And then I have the ability to go back to our service
teams and say, hey, I talked to these customers,
this is what they need
and be able to advocate for customers and
future road maps and capabilities in
our services.
So you know these challenges are what we're
hearing from customers,
and I also had the opportunity to experience
that when I was a customer. I was a customer for about
8 years,
part of a team that built a, um,
security platform, a SAS security platform,
uh, in AWS, and like many
of you may have experienced, we started with,
you know, 3 developers and one account and
scaled that out to hundreds of accounts
and very complex services that served
our customers.
And so we experienced some of these challenges
as part of that as well,
and I'll note that the challenges that I'm going to
share here and talk through, um,
are just the tip of the iceberg we know there's
many more, but these are very common from what
we've heard. The first is
resources. Um, does anybody here
have
more, uh, human resource
capacity
than they know what to do with, uh,
more budget for tools
than you know what to do with?
I don't see any hands raised, right?
In fact, it's quite the opposite. Everybody's struggling
to be able to get, uh, more done
with less and less,
particularly as we enter the AI age.
And the expectation is that you can utilize
technologies like that to help you do even
more with even less
so we know that implementing
the principles that we're talking about today, the
solutions, uh, is, is a challenge
because we need resources to be able to
do that. So that's acknowledged.
The second is being able to,
you know, as we get into more detail about, uh,
cloud governance, when you think about implementing
controls across those four
domains we mentioned
across an entire environment, being able
to define those,
deploy those, and maintain those
is not an easy thing to do, right, and we acknowledge
that. Um,
3rd, and when we think about that agile
development cycle and, and supporting a culture
of agility.
We recognize there's a there's a balance point.
There's a balance between giving a lot of
control and independence to developers,
but also on the other end trying to maintain
standards and controls from a security
and cost and compliance perspective,
so maintaining that balance is always tricky.
And then lastly and certainly not least
is maintaining uh compliance
with ever evolving standards
um and I'm sure
you all here are subject to
multiple compliance frameworks. Anybody
uh specifically subject to
PCI DSS in your world,
OK? So you all probably know
that when PCIDSS 4.0
was, was launched or released in
2022.
There were
60 new controls added
to the framework,
right? So when you have that dropped in your lap and
now we need to deploy that across a complex
environment, that's a very challenging thing to do,
and that's, these are things that we acknowledge
and we hear from our customers,
uh, and we look to bring solutions for.
So you know, the good news is
that we look at again back to our definition,
we look at cloud governance
as a set of capabilities that helps you
achieve things and overcome some of these
challenges.
And what I'll be doing is walking through,
uh, calling out four characteristics
of Cloud Governance Foundation
and AWS
that will reflect some of what Dustin and
Lily went through, uh, in their transformation.
Um, so let's take a look at those.
The first characteristic
that we want to emphasize
is AWS cloud services provide
managed capabilities. So if you're
familiar with Control Tower,
you know that it can deploy,
configure,
and maintain for you up to 14
different underlying services,
and that relieves the pressure from you of having
to do that deployment configuration.
An ongoing management yourself. So
examples would be, uh, AWS
organizations,
IAM Identity Center,
uh, and AWS config,
which if you think about config just by
itself, there's a lot of complexity
in being able to deploy that and
manage it to your standards.
Control tower can do a lot of that heavy lifting for
you as a managed service
as it continues to be updated, uh,
behind the scenes by our teams. So manage
is number one.
Number 2, controlled.
So we talked about controls deploying that
across a complex environment.
Also, part of control tower is a set
of built-in controls
ready for you off the shelf to be able to deploy
across your environment.
So proactive controls, detective
controls, preventive controls
are there for you to, to implement
according to your needs
without having the need to build them
and deploy them
by yourself.
Back to agility,
so we think about again that tricky balance
and we'll use the count provisioning
and resource provisioning
as our example, being able to use
automation. And infrastructure as
code to allow your developers
to deploy the
resources that they need,
but doing so in a controlled way
according to your requirements is, is
really a critical element, and that's a lot of what we'll
be talking about today
using Account factory for terraform to
do deployments for you according to
preset
conditions that you want,
uh, enabling that agility.
And then last is scalability,
being able to deploy
uh uh uh uh uh a requirement
at scale across an entire scope
of accounts and resources in
one motion,
um, you know, we, we'll talk again
about Account factory for terraform and how it
enables you to, to, to
manage a large and complex, uh,
environment, multiple accounts and resources.
In one motion, so
based on those four characteristics, uh,
we're gonna have Dustin come up and
walk through a transformation that,
uh, Lilly and Company, uh, went
through to, uh, modernize their,
uh, cloud governance environment, Dustin.
Thank you Tim. Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Dustin Jefford. I am the
cloud platform or cloud foundation lead
at Eli Lilly and Company for our AWS
platform. Today I'm gonna
talk to you, as Tim mentioned,
about our journey into
modern cloud governance, specifically
our transition
from the legacy AWS landing
zone or ALZ solution into
control tower,
an account factory with Terraform.
But first, a little bit about who we are.
Um, Lilly unites caring
with Discovery to create medicines that make
life better for people around the world.
Founded in 1876
and headquartered in Indianapolis,
we employ more than 44,000
people worldwide.
Uh, we do clinical research in more than 55
countries
and we market our products globally.
With the global scale of our business.
We require governance technologies that
are robust,
scalable,
and ready to adapt to the constant changing
demands of working around the world.
Our journey in central cloud governance
and organization management really
began in 2018
when we adopted the ALZ or
the AWS landing zone.
At the time,
Lily was expanding rapidly into the cloud, as
I'm sure a lot of businesses were,
and we needed a way for our central
teams
to manage that expansion so that developers
and application teams could use those
services safely.
Uh, however, the very next year,
AWS released Control Tower,
and while we were very excited to see
a managed solution become available,
we had already invested very heavily
in Landing Zone.
At the time we were managing
somewhere between
40 and 500 AWS
accounts in our organization,
um,
and offering
3 to 4 standard account patterns.
We had also tied some critical
foundational automation
to where,
um,
to the landing zone, so network configurations
and identity,
um,
identity management permissions.
Uh, and so we decided at that time
to continue to invest
in landing zone until control tower
could mature to meet some of our needs.
Uh, and that continued all the way up through 2023
with the final release of the AWS landing
zone. By that point we were,
uh, up to I think 6 standard account
patterns, uh, numerous ad hoc
custom custom account patterns,
uh, and somewhere between 140 and
1500.
AWS accounts
as we continued to grow in
scale.
The initial advantages we found with
the ALZ service, the ability
to deploy
configuration changes across all of
our accounts at scale.
Became a hindrance
The monolithic pipeline approach of ALZ
as we
continue to create and grow.
Uh, into the environment
started taking longer and longer to push changes.
By the time we hit 2023,
a single execution of the pipeline
would take us eight hours to complete,
and that's assuming that it finished,
right? More often than not it started to
fail. Um,
and so
we found and watched the
central teams become a bottleneck
for innovation for the business.
That led us then to 2024
when we made a decision to
invest in and modernize
our governance solution.
So as we looked at our landscape.
Uh, and looked through and, um,
what we
wanted out of a new solution. We identified
a couple of critical requirements,
um. First, the
new solution.
Needed to be a managed solution,
uh, as much fun as it was managing
a bespoke custom
monolithic giant landing
zone, uh, we really didn't
want to deal with that operational overhead.
Uh, moving forward.
We needed to enhance and enhance and
increase agility
for both our central teams and for
our business teams.
And service areas
too often, as I mentioned,
we found ourselves being the bottleneck
to innovation.
We also needed to increase scalability.
We needed um
The business was not going to continue,
um. The business was
not going to stop expanding into
the cloud, and we needed to be able to handle
the increase.
As we need to be able to handle the business increasing
in that direction.
And we needed to simplify our governance.
I alluded earlier to some
critical foundational automation pieces
er that were tied to some of our early
landing zone architecture.
Uh, and that resulted in overly
complex SCPs,
um, and
really intricate conditional statements,
and I'll talk a little bit more, uh, about that, but
we needed to simplify that so that we could adopt
new features.
And that led us to control tower
with the Count factory for terraform.
And so in 2024 we worked with
AWS Professional Services to kick
off a project
to transition all
1500 accounts and the tens,
um, hundreds of thousands of resources
being managed by our foundational code
from
ALZ.
Into control tower and AFT.
Uh, we kicked off a six month
project. Um,
beginning at the end of 2024.
And going through the beginning of 2025,
we picked this time frame because there's lower
developer activity at Lily uh over the
end of the year time frame and we felt like
it would reduce the potential impact
to ongoing
initiatives and potential product releases.
But what that did mean
is that we needed to be able to do this
quickly so that we didn't impact anything
coming in the new year
and we needed to do this transparently.
We could not
have any downtime or potential for downtime,
uh, for any of our foundational and centralized services.
So what does this look like?
Um, the first thing we did isn't actually
on this slide, but we enrolled, uh,
we stood up control tower and then we enrolled
all of our accounts and OUs
into control tower.
Once we got that finished, or I guess rather
in parallel.
We went and decoupled our resources
from the old cloud formation stacks
that landing zone uses to manage the
resources. We did this
by updating all
of our resource definitions
to use the deletion policy retain
statement. And what that
simply means for anyone who doesn't know is that
If you then or when you delete
the cloud formation stacks, the resources
remain behind, they don't get deleted,
so we went back through and there was a lot of
um.
Repeated executions of that monolithic pipeline,
so it took us a while, but we got
all of those resource definitions updated.
Then we went and developed terraform modules
to replace those resource definitions,
and this is where we did take some
opportunity
to simplify some of our automation and decouple
some things.
Um
Once we completed that,
Uh, and those two steps very much manual,
and once we completed that, we implemented
an automation. We've implemented, uh, we
designed and implemented some step functions
and lambdas
that did a couple of things for us and helped
accelerate this transition.
Uh, the first thing that it did,
uh, is it went, uh, across the entire
environment
and scraped all of
our deployed stack sets, our foundational
deploys deployed stack sets.
Uh, pulled in all of the input
parameters and output values,
sent that over to Amazon Bedrock.
I think it was the Cloud 3 model at the time.
And used AI to generate
terraform import commands.
Those commands were then manually validated
as they came back to make sure there weren't any unexpected
create or delete
statements in there.
And once we validated that, we, we
approved the continuation of the script execution,
uh, and the script executed those imports
for us and generated, uh,
a series of state files.
We then took those state files
and uploaded those to the account
factory for terraform code base
and registered each account
with AFT,
uh, and then the script executed those AFT
pipelines
and Alex will talk a little bit more about what
what that looks like in detail.
But once those pipelines were executed,
we got
a second or a 3rd piece of validation
that no resources were being destroyed
or changed or retained or um.
Or rebuilt
and
effectively it would it synchronized
AFT
with the resources deployed so at this
point all resources are
now being managed through control tower
and through Account factory for terraform.
And then we went back and we deleted
those cloud formation stacks and decommissioned
the ALZ environment.
And by using this process you see
3 of the steps, the big chunk
of the of the process is
automated by doing this.
We were able
to move all
1500 AWS accounts, the tens
of thousands of resources associated
with those stacks.
From ALZ
and into control tower, uh,
within 6 months, uh, 3 months
upfront development time
and then the automated piece, uh, took
about
3 months to complete.
One other advantage I wanted to highlight
that we were able to um.
To do as part of this, which
has resulted in significant benefit for us.
When we initially built out
the ALZ.
As I mentioned, we tied a number of pieces of.
Core foundational
functionality to
specifically where an account sat
within the org hierarchy.
So if you were in a dev account you got
dev permissions
and a dev.
Networking set, uh a
dev set of networking configurations that
you could use.
And this resulted
in a very flat OU structure.
Made things very complicated, very difficult
to manage from a central perspective. We had redundant
SCPs.
Um, and very complex
SCP conditionals.
Uh, so not just complex
to manage, but complex to expand on.
When new features were released like RCP.
Or resource control policies, we
struggled to get those features implemented.
By decoupling that automation from the
OU when we refactored our
resource definitions into terraform.
It allowed us to adopt a more
hierarchical
organization and OU structure.
We went with a workloads-based
architecture for a number of reasons.
Um,
but what this did allow for is
significant reduction in the
number of redundant guard rails,
uh, oh, way, way simplified,
um, SCP configurations,
uh, conditionals became.
Very straightforward in the few times in the few
instances where we still needed them.
Um,
and easier onboarding of new patterns.
Um
Prior to this adoption.
We had uh central teams who maybe
wanted to
host an EKS cluster
for the, for the global organization,
right? Prior
to this.
The
The upfront foundational changes
that would be needed to allow EKS
to run in the way that they need it to run
would take a minimum of 1 to
2 months of development time.
And implementation,
executing that 8 hour long pipeline,
adjusting,
executing again, promoting the production.
Executing again, testing,
um. With
this change we are now able
to set up a new OU
for a workload that is non-standard
and execute the and apply
any required SCP changes
within the space of a sprint, so 2 weeks,
so a significant reduction.
In implementation time from the central
teams. And
so what does this, what does this look like from an
outcomes perspective?
75% reduction in manual
effort, 300%
increase in code push frequency.
Faster creation of OUs
and feature delivery, like I said, from 2 months
down to 2 weeks.
Security and configuration updates can
now be deployed across all accounts in under
5 hours.
And it's nice to see the percentages up here, but what
this looks like
in reality for Lily
is we were able, so we finished this
project in
Q1 of 2025,
that next quarter before we had
really been able to continue
to invest and build out
our control tower and AFT presence,
we saw.
And we're able to push more.
Configuration changes
in that quarter in Q2 than we were
able to push in the entirety of the previous
year,
2024.
And so we no longer
are a blocker to innovation for our business
teams. Because
As much as I can point to these numbers
up here. Lily's
journey to modern cloud governance is
more.
Is about more than just technology.
It's about empowering our teams and accelerating
innovation,
and ensuring that our infrastructure can
keep pace with our mission to improve
lives around the world.
And now I'll welcome Alex to the stage
to talk a little bit more about control tower.
Thank you.
Good afternoon everybody.
A quick question for everyone.
How many of you heard about our controls only
experience that launched last week?
See this is like the common thing I've heard
all week. uh, I did a little bit of booth duty
on the expo floor the other day
and everyone kept coming up to me like, hey, I wanna be able to
use landing zones and I wanna be or I wanna be able
to just use managed controls, but.
I don't wanna just set up landing zones. We'll, we're gonna
get into that a little bit today.
So bringing it all together first
with AWS control tower for those that are a little
unfamiliar, uh, we orchestrate
a lot of services on your behalf.
Uh, this allows you to really focus on
the,
uh,
security and compliance needs of your organization.
You can get started in under 30 minutes or, or
less, uh, with AWS control
tower. Well, let's walk through a little bit
of what we set up for you.
So first, when you set up control tower, you're gonna
get two accounts.
Uh, you're going to get a log archive account and you're going
to get an auditing account.
Both of these accounts help meet your logging
in requirement needs within your organization.
And then next we're gonna set up two OUs for you.
Now you have the ability to make the sandbox
OU optional, but,
uh, what is not optional is the security
OU, which comes preconfigured with two
additional accounts.
One has your AWS backup vaults in it,
and the other one's a delegated administrator account where
you can manage your AWS backup service.
And then last Account factory lives within
control tower.
Now Account factory allows you to provision
specific types of um uh AWS
accounts
uh to your organization
using account baseline resources that you've
perused from the managed controls catalog and uh
and applied to your organization.
There's 3 additional value adds that
I wanna call out really quickly for
control tower.
So number 1,
you do get AWS identity, uh,
identity Center federated
access to your applications.
Number 2, we're gonna enable AWS
config
and AWS cloud shell, and we're gonna write
those
both to a centralized S3
bucket that's located in your log archive
account. And then last, any
of those managed controls that you've
uh turned on for your landing zone,
uh will be backed by security hub,
cloud trail, and cloud formation,
and that ensures that any newly provisioned
accounts do meet those compliance standards that you've
set in place already.
So we talked a little bit about
Account factory
in the previous slide, and I do want to talk a
little bit more in depth about that, so.
Uh, Account Factory exists to help
provision those AWS accounts for you with
those preconfigured either security baseline
resources or maybe it's some of those managed controls that
you put in place,
uh, but we also just released a new feature when
it comes to, um,
Account factory
that allows you to, uh, Account
Factory to live with completely within AWS
control tower using the AWS
organization's account primitives,
and it no longer requires the previous required,
uh, service catalog integration.
So how does this look today?
You're gonna go ahead and just navigate directly
to your AWS management console for
organizations and create your account
there, or you can use the programmatic call
create account API from AWS
organizations. Once the account has been provisioned,
all you're gonna do is go ahead and move that OU
or move that account to the control tower OU
and then once it's placed in that OU.
Uh, we'll apply any of those managed
controls that you selected from the control catalog. We'll
also put any of those preconfigured services
there, uh, so cloud trail, config,
backup, anything along those lines.
So now we're gonna walk a little bit through Account
factory for terraform and what that kind
of looks like. So uh right hand of the
screen, of course, one of the
very specific things that you're gonna need is you're gonna need
control tower deployed.
Uh, next, after that you're gonna set up an
account factory administration account.
This is specifically just for account factory.
Uh,
going back to the right hand side, I just want to point out
here that we did just mention that
service catalog is no longer required, but for the purposes
of this discussion,
we're here.
And the big call out here is like any
of your account vending or account orchestration
needs are gonna occur in that block.
So this is a GitOps driven model, so
um. Essentially a user
will create an account request file
within the account factory configuration repository
and commit it via get Push into the repo.
In this scenario we are using AWS Code
commit, but we do support any uh
code star connection request.
Next, once you've, uh, pushed the
pushed that change, uh, it'll activate your code
pipeline and write those changes to
Amazon Dynamo DB.
This gives you a traceability plan for any of those
changes.
Next, Account Factory is gonna go ahead and
communicate
with AWB's control tower to figure out
does this account need to be updated or
do I need to provision a new account?
If yes, it'll go directly to control tower to
make those vending requests and vend
your account as specific. If it doesn't
need to do that, it's gonna go straight to applying
some of those customizations
that you've already defined. So
maybe some of those networking configurations that you want
specific to your organization.
Maybe it's some security guard rails that you set up in the very
beginning. All of that occurs there
And then last, Account factory
applies defined account level specific
or global customizations using
terraform.
Uh, when we deploy these configurations
within the account, whether it's newly provisioned
or updated, the account then meets all of
your specific compliance needs or security
needs that you're setting forth as an organization.
So now that you've heard about Account
Factory,
uh, you've heard a little bit about Terraform,
how it's technically
executed,
how Eli Lilly is using it. Why should
you guys use it?
So first,
Account Factory customizes new and
existing
accounts through a pipeline-based workflow.
This meets the requirements of your
organization to meet scalability or agility needs,
uh, as it automates the entire workflow on
your behalf.
And for customers using Terraform, it fulfills
the gap of your uh infrastructure
as code as a gap.
Number 2,
deployment and configuration artifacts are
stored in version control repositories.
This this is important because it ensures that
you're working up the most up to-date code
and it gives you traceability of that code.
I have to do a rollback. Well, good thing I already have
this stored in, in a stored repository.
Third, we support published modules
from the terraform registry and custom
modules.
This gives customers a starting point,
but it also enables you to fully customize the
environment to what you need. You need to tailor it specific
to what your requirements are, whether
you're PCI needs, whether
you're HIPAA compliant, or any of these other specific
compliance frameworks that you're looking for.
And then last, for our really security minded folks,
we support delegated administration.
A lot of customers come to us and say, hey, I
don't wanna log into the management account every day to
do specific actions. What can you do to help
me here? Well,
we have still we have delegated admin for that.
Next I wanna talk a little about
controls
and what that means.
So recently we've heard a lot
about shifting to the left.
Has anyone ever heard the term shifting to your left
in any of your
all hands meetings, any security meetings?
See a couple of hands in the crowd? Awesome.
So we're shifting left from just detective
controls, right? Contractive controls were
designed to alert you after an event has
already occurred.
We're shifting to the left.
With proactive controls,
controls that are designed to prevent
resource mutation from occurring.
And going even further, we're shifting farther to
the left with preventative controls.
Controls that are there to ensure that
no bad code is ever shipped to your production
environments.
So what does this look like in the controls catalog?
So. The controls catalog is
a single source of truth for AWS
managed controls, and soon we're gonna
have all of the AWS managed controls
here. With our recent launch with
the controls only experience, now you can
go directly to the controls catalog
without having to set up that landing zone requisite.
So I can go here,
peruse whatever controls I need, any metadata,
any of those corresponding compliance frameworks,
and apply those controls really easily.
If you need detective controls, you're gonna go
ahead. And activate AWS config
at an account level, at an OU level,
organization wide.
You want proactive or preventative controls,
all you're gonna do is enable trusted
access and choose what regions you wanna operate in as
well. It's never been easier
to activate some of these managed controls for your
environments than today, and I can't harp on
that enough just because I've heard so
much from customers this week saying like we definitely just
wanna like use controls for our environments.
We have such a hard time
getting through some of our auditing pieces or like
looking at the.
These compliance pieces, well, I
very much urge everyone after this call, go
and tell your teams, go check out the manage controls.
So now that we've talked about a little bit
about Account factory, uh, how it customizes
your accounts, uh, the value of
managed controls as well, how do we bring
them together?
You heard Dustin talk about how they migrated
to Control Tower and established their
account factory pipeline infrastructure.
Figuring out how to protect your workloads with
managed controls is next,
so you can deploy those managed controls using
terraform within your uh account factory
pipelines
to keep resource deployments
within a single approach.
How is this beneficial to us?
It's simple to manage.
You're essentially baking everything into a single pipeline,
and that reduces your costs, your operational
costs,
but it does come back with some
drawbacks.
So you're going to have your account factory
administrator is going to have permanent
elevated permissions.
And secondly, you are taking dependency risk
by relying on a single account factory
pipeline in that scenario.
So how does it look again?
I'm gonna take us back to the architecture slide that I showed
in the very beginning.
So any of those, um,
deployed controls within your account factory pipeline
will essentially be baked in the uh
AWS code build and ADWS step functions piece
where you're applying the customizations directly.
But if you wanna use terraform,
everything is gonna occur in that green box there.
It ensures that deployments are
done through a single approach and that you can keep track
of where anything is.
And I'm gonna bring Tim back up to
talk about our key takeaways. Thanks everyone.
Thank you, uh, Alex, and thank you Dustin.
Um, one of my favorite things about a
customer led, uh,
session like this
is the impact on the business so we talked
about enabling organizations
through improving governance and becoming
more modern and in, in the case of
Lilly it's a really meaningful outcome
because that is enabling them really.
Uh, indirectly to help create
better products for their customers, which is a very
meaningful output. So we like to connect these
technical things that we're talking about to real world,
uh, and that's a real meaningful one. So
we do wanna hit on three kind of technical
takeaways again. Our goal here is always that
somebody, you'll come away with something,
uh, that either reinforces what you've done
or inspires you to look into something else that
can help you
advance, uh, your operations and
advance your organization.
So we'll touch on 3 takeaways. The
first one.
Is
being able to leverage this governance
foundation
to enable these organizational
objectives we didn't touch much on resilience
today, but it ties in as well,
but enabling agility,
uh, and scale and moving
faster is one of the the core
objectives here and we hope you pick something up
from from this session that could drive
that for your organization.
Uh, the next one is.
Being being able to simplify
uh the the the the governance
operation through
uh services like uh Count factory
for Terraform,
uh, being able to leverage something that was built
to drive automation and standardization
is a way for you to simplify
your operation and, and provide consistency,
uh, and, and, and compliance.
The 3rd
Is
managed right being able to leverage
managed services and in and in particular
what Alex mentioned about managed
controls is super super
important. And I, and I'll add to that
that you know, as I mentioned earlier, I'm constantly
talking to customers and working with our service
teams. We're always looking
to add more to our controls library,
right? The things that you need
to drive consistency, compliance,
meeting your costs,
security, uh, operational
and compliance standards, we, we
continue to add to our repo
of rules that again are managed
for you, uh, behind the scenes, so.
Uh, hopefully those
some of that resonated and you could take some things
away, uh, and, and work on that
following up with your account teams.
We of course would love to talk to you
afterward. We'll, we, we'll be kind of lingering
around and happy to, to take some questions,
uh, and. And connect with us, uh,
afterward
and then last but not least, um, please
make sure to go into the
uh app and complete the survey
uh that's our request of you.
uh, we thank you so much for being here and spending
the whole uh session with us so enjoy
the rest of reinvest.